uh Ron DeSantis had a book event
and he had all the Trump supporters
kicked out
is this free speech
is this inclusiveness is this a big tent
party this is one of my absolute
favorite things this week extremist
Laura Loomer who I think very little of
she went with a bunch of trump people to
a a DeSantis event
in Leesburg Florida it was a book event
books a million and the Trump people
were kicked out by security because the
DeSantis people said they've got to go
now remember DeSantis isn't even running
Trump's not DeSantis his opponent in any
official sense right now and in addition
to that Trump did endorse DeSantis for
governor albeit pretty half-heartedly so
it's wild that this is going on take a
look at this video of security
telling Laura Loomer and all of the
Trump people the DeSantis people are
kicking you out
I mean listen all these people are nuts
but anybody wearing Trump has to go
right now is whacked stuff
[Music]
this isn't like you know if you try to
go to a if Ron DeSantis declares that
he's running and a bunch of people try
to get into the rally with Trump signs
obviously they're going to take the
Trump signs and probably kick you out
that's a political rally this is not a
political rally this is a very different
thing and they're still kicking these
people out
of call the police now then there's
another clip here where the security guy
even seems to say to these folks you're
acting like the far left it's it's crazy
what is happening but the big story is
Trump supporters kicked out DeSantis
doesn't want Trump supporters there here
we go
uh oh
boy looks like our clip froze here let's
see if we can reset here and get it
going because this is a critical clip
are you acting like the bar
acting like the far left trying to get
Trump elected
yeah well you're acting like the far
left
brilliant security guard huh
trying to get Trump elected far left yes
trying to get Trump elected is the far
left
I am a trump supporter technically
technically you shouldn't be over there
then
how crazy is this American right wing
movement just people everybody's brain
is just has been replaced with
mayonnaise but
so private property you need to leave
okay
told them that anybody who's wearing a
trump hat or anything anything Trump
they have to leave so we're you know
Governor DeSantis likes to pretend like
he's a governor in favor of free speech
but really he allows for elections to be
stolen by big Tech and now all right
anyway so they're going into those
criticisms
um and then here's one more clip of the
same uh listen guy uh the security guard
supports Trump but he's just doing his
job
and me come out
not to be here why he's here
like he always talks about how he's in
favor of free speech like we have a
First Amendment right to be here rally
in support of president right you do
right so but not now that's so great you
do have that right but I'm suspending
that right as regards to this parking
lot while Ron DeSantis is in there
citing signing books oh my God this is
going to be an insane primary so not
exactly four I guess uh the speech of
these people uh out in your parking lot
even not even inside the event DeSantis
just doesn't want to see them
um and this is uh
I get it DeSantis wants the book signing
to be about him rather than about Trump
but when Trump is supposedly a political
Ally Who endorsed you and who support
you welcomed and all of this stuff uh
kicking all of these people out is
pretty wild so we'll have all of these
clips on our Instagram you can search
Instagram for David Pacman show and if
you're interested in getting these clips
in Spanish for your Spanish-speaking
friends and relatives go to
davidpackman.com
Spanish make sure you're subscribed to
the Spanish Channel
imagine for a second that you try
logging into your email account only to
find that your password was changed an
hour ago and then you get notifications
of activity from your bank and then your
credit cards that is what identity theft
is like and it's a horrible feeling and
we dealt with it at the show not that
long ago but now I have an app called
Aura which gives me much more peace of
mind our sponsor Aura is the all-in-one
solution for keeping your online account
safe because Aura will scan the dark web
for your personal info passwords social
security number and you get fast alerts
when they find something you also get
fast alerts about credit inquiries Aura
protects all of your devices from
malware or even requests the removal of
your info from data broker sites and
Aura helps you manage what your kids can
do on their devices you can restrict
certain apps set screen time limits set
Focus times when you need them off of
devices is go to aura.com Pacman to try
it free for seven days your login
credentials might already be floating
around out there and Aura will tell you
instantly for free the link is down
below